Good morning.
It's the morning after
Thanksgiving and I'm still
feeling sick with food,
but I will move
forward and do SAT videos.
So we are on the third test in
The Official SAT Study Guide
on page 518.
This is section two, so it's the
first math section in this
third test.
And let's get started with the
problems. The first problem is
3x plus 9 is equal to 5x plus
1, and they want to know x.
So this just a straightforward
algebra problem.
Well, what we can do is, since
we don't have negative
numbers, let's subtract
1 from both sides.
So you get 3x plus
8 is equal to 5x.
Subtract 3x from both sides,
you get 8 is equal to 2x.
Divide both sides by 2, you get
4 is equal to x, or x is
equal to 4, choice D.
Problem number two.
That was just a straightforward
problem.
Problem number two.
They give us a little sequence
here, so let's see, 7, 15, 31,
63, and it just keeps going.
And it says, the first term in
the sequence was 7, and each
term after the first is
determined by multiplying the
preceding term by m,
and then adding n.
So we multiplied by m
and then added n.
OK, what is the value of m?
Well, you can just look at what
they're doing, right?
What do you have to multiply
7 by and add to get to 15?
Well, 7 times 2, plus 1
is equal to 15, right?
7 times 2, plus 1
is equal to 15.
And then if you do 15 times
2, plus 1, you get 31.
15 times 2, plus 1 is equal
to 31, and so forth.
31 times 2, plus 1 is
equal to 63, right?
So in general, you're taking--
they're saying, each term
after the first is determined
by multiplying the preceding
term by m, and then adding p.
So we're multiplying by
2 and then adding 1.
And they want to know what m is,
so we're multiplying by 2.
So the choice is B.
Next problem, number three.
And I'll switch colors
for this one.
On number three, I went
to a bolder yellow.
OK, so that was two
tables, they're
T-shirts, so there's color.
They have red, white,
and blue.
And then under size they have
small, medium, large, and
extra large.
The table above shows the
different colors and sizes of
T-shirts that are available at
Independence High School.
How many different combinations
of color and size
are possible?
Well, for each color there
are four sizes, right?
So you just multiply the number
of colors times the
number of sizes, right?
There's four reds, four
whites, four blues.
So it's 3 times 4 is equal
to 12, choice B.
Once again, that was just a very
straightforward problem,
no real tricks there.
Problem number four.
We're just going through these
problems. For which of the
following functions is-- and
they write-- let me clear this
because this might
take some space.
OK, so they say, for which
of these functions is the
following true: f of negative
3 is greater than f of 3?
And here are their choices.
So choice a: f of x is
equal to 4x squared.
Well, in this situation, we
can just look at this.
f of negative 3 and f of 3 is
going to be the same thing,
because when you square the x
term, f of negative 3 is going
to be 4 times 9, which is the
same thing as f of 3, right?
So that's not going
to help us.
I got the 9 because I squared
the negative 3, or squared the
3, so this isn't the
right choice.
f of 3 is equal to f of
negative 3, choice a.
Choice b: f of x is going
to be equal to 4.
Well, once again, this isn't
going to be our choice,
because f of x is the same
number no matter what, right?
It's 4, so there's no way that f
of negative 3 is going to be
greater than f of 3.
So b is not our answer.
Choice c says f of x is
equal to 4 over x.
Well, this has possibility.
So f of negative 3 is what?
Minus 4/3.
And f of 3-- well, no, this
isn't going to work.
It's going to be positive 4/3,
so actually f of 3 is larger
than f of minus 3.
So that doesn't work.
Choice e: f of x is equal to
4 minus x to the third.
This has potential, because
f of negative 3 is what?
It's 4 minus minus 27, which
equals 31, while f of 3 is 4
minus 27, which equals
minus 24.
So f of negative 3 is
larger than f of 3.
So our answer is e.
Next problem.
We don't have to do the last
one, because we already found
one that fits our answer and
that solves our problem.
Different colors.
OK, I will switch
to this color.
OK, five.
The force required to stretch
a spring beyond its natural
length is proportional
to how far the
spring is being stretched.
And if you've taken physics,
you'd probably see this.
The force necessary is equal
to some k, right?
Which is the proportionality
constant times how far you're
stretching.
That's all they're
saying, right?
The force required to stretch
a spring beyond its natural
strength is proportional--
so that's what k means,
proportional-- to how far the
spring is being stretched. x
is how far its being
stretched.
If a force of 15 pounds-- so
when F-- if a force of 15
pounds stretches a spring 8
centimeters-- so 15 pounds
stretches 8 centimeters--
we've got to [? solve ?]
for length-- what force, in
pounds, is needed to stretch
the spring 20 centimeters beyond
its natural length?
So we can just solve for k in
this equation and then apply
it here, right?
This is x.
So 15 is equal to k times
8, or we could say k is
equal to 15 over 8.
So we know that k is
And then here we have-- well,
what happens when x
is 20, what is F?
Well then, F is equal to k, 15
over 8, times how far this
thing needs to be stretched
beyond its natural length.
So 15 over 8 times 20.
What is this?
So we can divide the top
and the bottom by 4.
So this goes 5, 2.
And what's 5?
What's 5 times 15?
5 times 15, 75.
So it's 75 over 2.
And that's a strange number, but
it looks like we do have
choices that match that.
And that's 37.5, which
is choice E.
Next problem.
Actually, I've probably run out
of time, so I will do the
next problem in the
next video.
See you soon.